[Music]
the graphics department
give me that weird man bun no one even
asked about that that's not a man bun
that's just a bun that's just a bum yeah
all right okay that's a bun that's a bun
all right let's talk about this mr.
robot okay give the day I was watching
mr. robot not watching I didn't really
know it was going on so I hit the info
button and it said a dysfunctional but
brilliant hacker seeks to bring down the
system
oh well never even once blinking so I
watched a bachelor in paradise you ever
check that show out I am now yeah
bachelor in paradise and as watching his
then I hit the info button and said the
same questionable sexual choices now
with 30% more Zika
[Applause]
yeah Ice Road Truckers I was watching
Ice Road Truckers yeah didn't know it
was going on hit the info button got a
crappy job
feel free to pitch it as a show bit of
the History Channel as watching the show
I was watching sex drugs and rock and
roll yeah and then I hit the info button
and set a powerful docu-series about
Denis Leary's transition to Suze Orman
we're very very affected women Dateline
I was watching paint line huh yeah
Dateline and then hit the info button
this turns out your wife is wrong you're
not the worst husband in the world the
night of I was watching the night up
uh-huh yeah then I hit the info button
said if you watch one serialized true
crime drama that all of your friends
tell you you must watch let this be the
one of the six of those on cable right I
don't like it murder on cable the Real
Housewives of Melbourne mm-hmm the Real
Housewives of Melbourne and then I hit
the button
tonight Darby's mate gets her crimper up
on the old covers Wampus before Shelley
shags the deadly doer tonight Toby's
mate gets a creepy old cobblers Wumpus
full Shelley shades of Delhi Dewar the
dead leg down Tower the People vs OJ
Simpson I've watered a bit yeah everyone
loved that miniseries people vs. OJ
Simpson and then I hit the info button
so good you'll hope Oh Jay murders again
I was at the end thinking and finally I
turned on this show I turned on Conan
yeah and I just thought I just I'm
curious so I hit the info button each
night a see-through piece of pumpkin
pasta hopes that this is the audience
that makes the pain go away
[Applause]
you